what's up guys this is an extremely
exciting day because I have been waiting
for a really long time for my math fro
to come in and it's finally arrived as a
lot of you guys know there's been a lot
of delays in shipping but honestly after
the dilemma of the GoPro karma I would
have waited an eternity for this so I
got the Mavic pro bundle so it comes
with the matic pro but it also comes
with a charging dock and the little bag
to put it in controller we've got our
charging utilities this looks like it's
an extra little cable that goes to your
controller so I'm gonna save this this
one looks like a micro USB so in case
you don't have an iPhone you can use an
Android phone or whatever phone happens
to support micro USB cable charging
brick lots of directions I'll set those
aside she looks great
here's our repellers it looks like the
bottom ones are already on so you just
got to put the top ones on this is
incredible it's a battery charging hub
also comes with a car charger two
batteries
I don't open this up I got a charger
real quick or my sister is gonna be very
upset with me car charger I'll just put
that in my car immediately battery
charging hub is very important so with
this a lot of people think that it
charges all four at the same time but it
actually will charge one once that one's
full it moves on to the next one
I don't want me to get back here can
literally they can either hello everyone
hi sweet meiody guys Maddy yeah this is
cool
Oh God if your head doesn't fit
[Music]
and we got a squeegee he's over here we
saw some people squeezing through here
that were much larger than us so we
figured this is going to be a much per
pet you guys turning 43 lights on hey
Google play me some Christmas music sure
check out this Christmas music radio mix
on YouTube you know Dasher dancer